welcome to the huberman Lab podcast
where we discuss science and
science-based tools for everyday
[Music]
life I'm Andrew huberman and I'm a
professor of neurobiology and
Opthalmology at Stanford School of
Medicine my guest today is Rick Rubin
Rick Rubin is a world-renowned music
producer having worked with an enormous
number of incredible artists producing
for instance Red Hot Chili Peppers
Beasty Boys Jay-Z John cash Adele Lady
Gaga Tom Petty and of course Slayer this
last year Rick also authored his first
book which is a truly incredible
exploration into the creative process
his book is entitled the creative act a
way of being Rick has appeared once
before on the huberman Lab podcast and
during that appearance he offered to
answer listeners and viewers questions
those questions were put in the comment
section on YouTube and we received
thousands of them so today Rick answers
your questions about the creative
process I also took note of the feedback
that when Rick previously appeared on
the hubman Lab podcast that perhaps I
spoke a bit more than the audience would
have preferred so today I refrain from
speaking too much and try and give as
much airtime as possible to Rick in
order to directly answer your questions
you'll notice that today's discussion
gets really into the Practical aspects
of the creative process the most
frequent questions that I receive for
Rick were ones in which people really
want to understand what his specific
process is each and every day as well as
when he's producing music or other forms
of Art and of course people want to know
what they should do specifically from
the time they wake up until the time
they go to sleep even whether or not
they should take note of their dreams
Etc we get into all of that so today's
discussion is very different from the
one I held with Rick previously and at
least to my knowledge from any of the
other interviews or discussions that
Rick has had publicly
before we begin I'd like to emphasize
that this podcast is separate from my
teaching and research roles at Stanford
it is however part of my desire and
effort to bring zero cost to Consumer
information about science and science
related tools to the general public in
keeping with that theme I'd like to
thank the sponsors of today's podcast
our first sponsor is Maui Nei venison
Maui Nei venison is the most
nutrient-dense and delicious red meat
available I've spoken before on this
podcast and there's General consensus
that most people should strive to
consume approximately at Le one gram of
protein per pound of body weight now
when one strives to do that it's
important to maximize the quality of
that protein intake to the calorie ratio
because you don't want to consume an
excess of calories when trying to get
that one gram of protein per pound of
body weight mauii venison has an
extremely high quality protein to
calorie ratio so it makes getting that
one gram of protein per pound of body
weight extremely easy it's also
delicious personally I like the ground
venison I also like the venison steaks
and then for convenience when when I'm
on the road I like the jerky the jerky
is a very high protein to calorie ratio
so it has as much as 10 grams of protein
per jerky stick and it has something
like only like 55 calories so again
making it very easy to get enough
protein without consuming excess
calories if you would like to try mauii
venison you can go to mauii venison
docomond to get 20% off your first order
again that's mauii venison
docomo to get 20% off today's episode is
also brought To Us by eight sleep eight
sleep makes Smart mattress covers with
cooling Heating and sleep tracking
capacity I've spoken many times before
in this podcast about the fact that
sleep is the foundation of mental health
physical health and performance now a
key component of getting a great night's
sleep is that in order to fall and stay
deeply asleep your body temperature
actually has to drop by about 1 to 3
degrees and in order to wake up feeling
refreshed and energized your body
temperature actually has to increase by
about 1 to 3° one of the best ways to
make sure that those temperature changes
occur at the appropriate times at the
beginning and throughout and at the end
of your night when you wake up is to
control the temperature of your sleeping
environment and that's what eight sleep
allows you to do it allows you to
program the temperature of your mattress
and sleeping environment such that you
fall and stay deeply asleep easily and
wake up each morning feeling incredibly
refreshed and energized I've been
sleeping on an eight- Sleep mattress
cover for almost 3 years now and it has
dramatically improve the quality of my
sleep so much so that when I travel and
I'm at a hotel or an Airbnb and I don't
have access to my eight sleep I very
much look forward to getting home
because my sleep is always better when I
sleep on my eights sleep mattress cover
if you'd like to try eight sleep you can
go to 8sleep.com
huberman to get $150 off their pod 3
mattress cover eights sleep currently
ships in the USA Canada UK select
countries in the EU and Australia again
that's 8sleep.com
huberman today's episode is also brought
To Us by waking up waking up is a
meditation app that offers hundreds of
meditation programs mindfulness training
and Yoga Nidra which is sometimes
referred to as nsdr I'm a longtime fan
of meditation I started meditating when
I was back in my teens and I started
doing a daily 10 or 20 minute meditation
and I kept that up for a number of years
but then it became more sporadic and
then eventually I stopped and then I'd
start again and then I'd stop what I
found with the waking up app is that it
makes it very easy to take on a
meditation practice and to do meditation
if not every day very close to every day
and that we know based on a lot of
research has an out size positive effect
on everything from stress regulation to
sleep you come up with better ideas so
indeed meditation can make you more
creative more focused and on and on and
then about 10 years ago I got introduced
to Yoga Nidra or nsdr non-sleep deep
rest which is a practice of laying
completely still while keeping the Mind
very active so you're relaxing but
keeping your mind active and I use nsdr
essentially every single day I'll do it
anywhere from 10 to 30 minutes and I
find it to be incredibly restorative it
really resets my ability to think and to
engage in physical activity and with
waking up I can select different lengths
of meditations different lengths of yoga
nras or ndrs so that I keep up my
practice if you'd like to try waking up
you can go to waking up.com huberman to
try a completely free 30-day trial again
that's waking up.com huberman to try a
free 30-day trial and now for my
discussion about protocols for
creativity with Rick Rubin Rick Rubin
welcome back
thank you sir happy to be here we're
going to answer or rather you are going
to answer the questions of the listeners
of our previous podcast
episode before we do that however when
we were out in the lobby you mentioned
that you have a breathing exercise a
coherence breathing exercise that you
thought might be useful for us to do now
and perhaps for some of the listeners to
join in yeah let's do it and then if you
want to talk about it after we can
sounds good the reason I started Ed
doing this is I have relatively low
heart rate variability and you want to
have a Higher One um so I looked at all
the things that can raise your heart
rate variability and I started doing
this breathing technique specifically
for heart rate variability then it went
up awesome so it's great tested great
let's do it together here play it'll say
take a deep breath and then when you'll
hear the sound of
a if you follow me for the first inhale
and exhale you'll know what sound means
what and you do this eyes closed CL
typically I do it eyes closed okay we'll
Close Our Eyes thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you
that was five
minutes I like that feels nice doesn't
it yeah I notice
I don't spontaneously breathe at that
CAD I breathed quite a bit faster mhm so
especially on the exhale mhm so once I
got into a rhythm of it yeah the mind
just goes pseudo random for me what
about for you does your mind tend to go
one place I do now I
count um so the reason I knew it was 5
minutes is because it's six breaths per
minute and I counted five 1 1 1 2 1 3 3
1 4 1 5 1 6 2 1 so I was occupied with a
task how often do you do that at least
once and sometimes twice a day I aim for
10 minutes a day but if I get to 20
minutes a day it it's uh noticeable in
my heart rate variability results do you
do the coherence breathing at a
particular times of day or just whenever
it occurs to you uh I think it depends
on where I am and what else is going on
in my life so it it there was I had a
window of a very specific thing that I
was doing I would do coherent breathing
and I would do squats just air squats
and um in one location where I didn't
have any other equipment and uh and then
I found a way
like where I was doing treading water
which you got to experience with me I
would tread water and then after
Treading Water I would get out of the
pool sit in the Sun and do the coherent
breathing great yeah we should probably
mention what uh the treading water was
about because people will wonder um very
briefly I went and visited Rick overseas
this summer and we spent a fair amount
of the
daytime um treading water while
listening to podcasts from a speaker on
the side of the pool and it was awesome
um time together as friends is awesome
time in the sun is
awesome learning from podcasts and
listening and being entertained by
podcast is awesome and then treading
water is awesome you're much better at
treading water than I am I was fatiguing
it's just as as I said when we were
doing it it's it's um it's like doing
stairs if you practice doing stairs it
gets easier to do stairs but nobody's
good at doing you know marathon runners
can't run up the stairs it's a you know
it's a particular thing and treading
water if you just do it in even in the
little bit of time that we were doing it
every day by the end of your stay
it was easier for you than when you
started definitely yeah you acclimate
quickly yeah I was able to adapt I was
impressed at your endurance and Treading
Water early on by the way I've continued
the Treading Water practice because I'm
fortunate to have a pool in my new place
yeah um I listen to your podcast truly
wow tetr grammaton love it uh love love
love it uh I listen to a few other
podcasts and I've started listening to
more episodes of the podcast that you
introduced me to which was history of
rock music and 500 songs Andrew an
English podcast great podcast real
indepth information about music yeah
yeah that was such a great trip thanks
for having me over there thanks for
coming it was fun Treading Water it was
loved the time with you and your family
so I'm going to I'll invite myself again
you're always welcome on the topic of
meditation uh one of the questions in
this list of questions we'll talk about
the list itself in a moment um was about
this anecdote that you've told me and
you've mentioned a few other places
apparently that you've once meditated
all the way from was it San Francisco to
New York or at Los Angeles uh to New
York flight it was either LA to New York
or New York to LA I can't remember and I
may have done it more than once the
question specifically was which
meditation did you do TM TM was the
first meditation I learned
Transcendental Meditation learned when I
was 14 it's a it's pretty much a default
uh setting for me now sometimes it'll
evolve from TM into breathing like I
might start by doing breathing before
the TM piece starts and I and the
breathing may just take the whole time
or it may turn from breathing into a
gratitude practice or a meta practice
which is a four phrases may I be filled
with loving kindness may I be well may I
be peaceful and at ease may I be happy
and you repeat those phrases over and
over and it starts may I and then
eventually if you've done it for a year
or so you could start saying may we for
your for your immediate family and then
May and then as you build up the charge
for your immediate family in another
year or so you can spread it to your
community and eventually after maybe
five years you can do it for the planet
so that's the Meta Meta
MTA amazing loving kindness practice and
are there any particular
links maybe you could pass us later and
we could put in the captions maybe one
that You' used I learned it from Jack
cornfield who's a Buddhist scholar and a
a brilliant teacher terrific uh what do
you think meditation has allowed you uh
afforded you as well as what it's helped
you avoid in terms of a daily practice
or um maybe in just how doing it once in
a while has Wicked out into areas of
your life this is probably a long list
of things but if you were to pick maybe
like the top three where you go yeah
when I'm meditating regularly blank
happens and blank doesn't happen and
when I'm
not those things because I've been doing
it for such a long time it's so um part
and parcel of who I am that without I
don't know who I would be without it
that said I don't always do it but I
don't have at this point I don't have to
always do it to be in this Zone where
I've been you know
for
almost you know 45 years it's been a big
part of my life
so a great deal of the benefits have are
in me now when I practice it get
Amplified but um as Maharishi described
it every time you meditate is like
making a deposit in a bank so it's
always there every time you do it it's
you're building a base and the goal of
the practice is less about the practice
it's about the practice is to change the
way you are in the
world so it's a practice for
life do do you know what I'm saying like
the the changes that come in the
meditation are to help your reactions in
the real world in some ways not to
trivialize it but it's like physical
exercise you know during a good workout
your blood pressure is really elevated
you're secreting all sorts of
inflammatory cyto kind you know if we
were to draw your blood midw workout uh
you'd say this person is in trouble yeah
but then all these wonderful adaptations
occur that allow you to sleep better
better mood walk upstairs easily and on
and on it's funny about sleeping better
this morning I was walking on the
beach and um had my headphones on wired
headphones and I was listening to a
podcast I can't remember what I was
listening to but I was listening to a
podcast and someone flagged me and
interrupted me who I didn't know and I
went over to talk to him and he said I
heard you talking about Steve Martin on
a podcast and uh and he told me a story
about Steve Martin that he got to see
him in 1979 I would say this person was
probably mid mid to late
60s and he was wearing all black he was
wearing shoes on the beach uh tennis
shoes he was wearing dark sunglasses and
a
hat and
um said uh just want to talk about
comedy and things that he heard me say
on a podcast and we talked about it for
a
while and then he said something about
he loves podcast and he listens to him
at night cuz he's got terrible insomnia
and he can't sleep and I'm looking at a
guy in the sun wearing sunglasses and I
said well you know the reason you can't
sleep is because you're wearing
sunglasses now like what are you talking
about I said well the way the the human
body works is we react to the sun the
sun is what tells us we're awake and
then at night when it's dark that's what
tells us to go to sleep so you're mixing
the signals to your body by wearing the
sunglasses and he said well well I'm a
dermatologist and you know I've been a
do he said he was a dermatologist for
the last 40
years and my whole practice is about
getting people to get out of the
Sun and and I I we started talking about
it and uh he he was all covered up I was
wearing um my my board short and nothing
else and and I said well I'm in the sun
you know hours every day and and he's
like aren't you worried about uh
cancer and I said no I I feel pretty
healthy I feel okay and then he said let
me see your back and I turned around he
looked at my back he's like you have
Perfect Skin he like they should study
you in a in a uh in an Institute I
said this is what normal this is what
normal healthy skin looks like if you're
you expose it to the Sun and he said so
you're saying everything I've been
teaching in my in my uh medical practice
for the last 40 years was wrong said yes
everything it was funny funny
conversation yeah it's interesting I
mean we could go down a deep rabbit hole
with this but you know listeners of this
podcast will know that I'm you know very
much a proponent of getting those
sunlight signals to the eyes at least
once a day in the morning but also in
the in the evening this I'll just share
with you um
now I learned from a a guest whose
episode we haven't um aired yet that the
what is so special about that morning
and evening sunlight are the contrasts
between blues and oranges blues and reds
blues and pinks that we can't always see
if there's cloud cover but they come
through and it's the mathematical
difference in their presence a
subtraction of a lot of blue and then
next to it a lot of orange or a lot of
blue and then next to it a lot of pink
that
triggers the body's understanding that
this is morning and evening and that
night is coming in the evening and that
it's time to be awake in the morning and
throughout the day in the middle of the
day when the sun is out and it's
overhead it looks like white light and
white light includes the blues and the
oranges and the pinks and the Reds but
the they subtract to zero because
they're all mixed together that's why it
looks just blue and white and so while
bright light is great throughout the day
it's those morning signals now the I
think the Dermatology Community is
starting to come online with the idea
that low solar angle sunlight early and
later in the day sunrise sunrising and
sun setting and I say that because
people always go oh do you have to see
across the Horizon that would be ideal
But Rising and
setting do not create the kind of skin
damage or eye damage that they've been
so concerned about and I think the next
step for the field of Dermatology is
going to be to start communicating with
the neuroscientists and the Circadian
biologists and and really uh learning
that so thanks for bridging that gap on
the beach this morning I I do think
that's how starts and then it Wicks out
headphones so um I made the choice a few
years ago to stop using the Bluetooth
headphones based on my personal
experience which was I kept getting
these cysts behind my ears which I was
told were lymph swellings of lymph they
would actually drain lymph if they got
big enough it was it was really gross
and kind of troubling I stopped using
them I didn't get them I started using
them again I started getting those lymph
things and and there was some
significant heat effects as well and
I've interviewed a couple people
including a neurosurgeon on the podcast
about um the level of emfs that come
from them and they were not concerned
others I've spoken to are concerned I'm
going to try and balance out the
conversation over time but my feeling
was look if there's any concern
whatsoever why would I use them and I so
I use the ones with wires yes but you
use the ones with wires that are even
one step further away from um Wi-Fi
transmitters there are ones with air
tubes
that I use depending on what's going on
um and those have no electrical um
there's no electric near your head it's
just an air tube where the sound is
traveling this actual sound is traveling
in the tube tiers I definitely sleep
better with the phone out of the bedroom
some people are now turning off their
Wi-Fi at night I think you and I are
both really aligned in the sense that
we've seen enough things come and go in
the health
space like dis encouraging remarks about
lifting weights like that's just for
bodybuilders and it now everybody knows
muscle bound you become muscle bound now
men and women elderly and young are
encouraged to do resistance training uh
Yogo used to be cast in this kind of
Magic Carpet realm breath work all this
stuff has become over time mainstream
but it's taken a very long time and the
road has been choppy and sometimes in my
opinion really unfair to the to the
practices and and their value I mean
these are zero cost practices in many
many cases that can really help people
and so when I look at something like
sunscreen or or you know Bluetooth
headphones or we're talking about some
of these things I wish I had a portal
into the future where we look back and
go like of course of course so what are
your thoughts on just kind of um health
and wellness as you've observed it in
the last 20 30 years I mean you've been
in this for a while I mean you paid
attention to mindfulness and mindbody
stuff you know what are your thoughts I
I try to live in as natural way as
possible I try to eat as few processed
foods as possible try to eat grass-fed
animals
um and and I use hardly any products of
any kind you know that that aren't just
something that grows or lives on the
planet there were a couple questions
about this I'll ask now um you lost a
tremendous amount of weight you look
great by the way thank you look super
fit every time I see you you're in
better and better shape um and uh that's
that's in that's your perception it's
not in fact the case for I'll accept it
I don't know when I see you each time
you I mean you're extremely mobile you
you're sleeping well you have a robust
life like you know I mean all the marks
of health and vitality
um so I've heard you mention before that
you lost a significant amount of weight
how much weight and how did you do it
135 lbs through a high
protein
low calorie low carb diet and that went
against the convention at the time uh
well the person who suggested it was uh
uh someone at UCLA so it was a
mainstream Doctor Who helped me with my
weight loss I had been a vegan at that
time which was not mainstream then and
it was very unhealthy but I did that for
20 some hot years because I believed in
the theory of it but it proved not not
to be um healthy for me do you think
that different diets likely work for
different people
yes so that not everyone necessarily
should do what you did no yeah no but I
I think most people would probably
benefit from healthy red
meat I'm saying that only because it's
so vilified in our culture yeah I agree
and I think the healthy piece is key
there to non-factory farmed animals um
which fortunately reasonably cost
sources that are becoming more available
M um well I'm going to start pulling
from the list of questions uh by the way
folks there were more than a thousand
questions in just the one-third print
out that I did um it's an intimidating
stack in front of you it's the most
notes I've ever put in front of me
during a guest uh discussion here on the
podcast and we are not going to ask you
every question but I've organized them
in a in a some sense of a coherent order
um did you organize them or did AI
organize them I organize them but that's
a great opportunity to ask you one of
the questions that came up several times
which was um what are your thoughts on
AI and its ability to um shape how music
is made how Visual Arts are made are you
one of these like scared of AI or do you
Embrace new technology I don't know
enough about it yet to to talk about it
what I will say is what what I find
interesting about art is the point of
view of the person and making it and I
don't know that AI has a point of view
of its own so and I don't know how
interesting it would be ai's point of
view uh but I like people's points of
view and what makes an artist a great
artist to me is something about their
point of view does something with to me
childhood a question for Rick ruin was
what activities did you find most
enjoyable and easy to get lost in as a
child
I love this question for you in
particular reading was a big part of my
life listening to music was a big part
of my life playing guitar along with
music can't really play but the idea of
playing along so it didn't have to
actually be good enough to play along
because I didn't have that skill set but
I like the experience of doing my best
to play along with something I was
listening to and um also magic uh
learning like shuffling cards in front
of a mirror and
um coin tricks and uh slide of hand was
just interesting to me do you still do
magic I don't okay at the time that
music took over my life I had to choose
between the two because both of them
were full-time life
Pursuits I went and saw a mentalist in
New York this summer with my sister AI
wind is his name ASI first name last
name
wind every time I I see a mentalist and
especially when I see aie I've seen him
twice it it blows my mind what are your
thoughts on mentalists as it's my
favorite form of magic it's the most
interesting because it it doesn't rely
on props it it's it's it's
pure
um it feels like pure magic MH you know
if if you have a box and you pull
something out of the box there's
probably something tricky about the box
but when someone can look at you and
tell you what you're
thinking it's just wild it's really wild
so I love
that after aie did his his act um when
we pseudo returned to reality cuz it
really does change the way you look at
things after that for quite a while
maybe forever I asked him if he was was
willing to share maybe just like one
nugget of insight into how he does what
he does with and of course I wasn't
expecting he was going to give away the
whole thing and he said um a lot of it
has to do with forming and erasing
memories in people quickly which sounds
very kind of dark and mysterious really
interesting yeah that maybe it's
possible to to erase memories wow people
like maybe what we thought we saw we
really didn't see or hear wow so I dig
that descrip yeah I'm going to bring him
out here by the way so we should all get
together I want to get him on the
podcast okay a full 10% of the questions
for you were around writer blocks
sticking
points this kind of thing like feeling
stuck in the creative process now people
didn't specify whether or not they were
stuck at the beginning the middle of the
end but based on my read of all of these
questions I got the sense that people
were feeling like there's something in
them that they want access to they want
to create but they don't know how to get
past that initial stage as opposed to
somebody who's like you know 90% done
and they just can't finish the last
10% what are your thoughts about these
kinds of blocks and how to overcome them
um any experience you've had with them
yourself and perhaps with uh working
with other artists the first thought is
to go past the idea of the block and
think about what what
is what's the cause of the
block and the block is usually something
like it's either a personal I'm not good
enough it's it can be a confidence
issue I don't have anything to
say or it could be a
um thinking about someone else nobody's
going to like what I
make do do you know what I'm saying so
it's either a A self-judgment or fear of
outside
judgment so if you're making
something with a with a freedom
of this is something I'm making for
myself for now that's all it
is it's a diary
entry everything I make is a diary
entry the beauty of a diary entry is I
can write my diary
entry and you can't tell
me my diary entry wasn't good enough or
that's not what I that's not what I
experienced of course it's what I
experienced it's I'm writing a personal
diary for myself no one else can judge
it it is my experience of of my
life everything we make can be that can
be a
personal reflection of who we are in
that moment of time it doesn't have to
be the greatest you could ever do it
doesn't have to have any expectation
that it's going to change the world it
doesn't have to be this has to sell a
certain number of copies for any reason
it doesn't have any of those things all
it is is I'm making this thing I'm
making this thing for me and I I want to
do it to the best of my ability to where
I feel good about it and where it's
honest it's honest of where I'm
at and if you're living in this world of
just being honest to where you're
at there's nothing blocking that do you
know what I'm saying there are no blocks
the blocks are all based
on dealing with a different force or a
different
perception that is made up you know you
make up this story and you're living the
story I'm in this block
because I just can't do it the reason
you can't do it is because you're afraid
someone else is not going to like it or
you're there are no blocks is there's
infinite amount of information out there
to work with because it doesn't it also
doesn't stem from us so we're we're
vehicles for this information and it's
coming through us all the time so if you
don't have an idea when you're sitting
at your desk if you go for a walk
chances are you'll see something that'll
spark something in you as a as a seed to
take off
from that makes a lot of sense
and I had a thought while you were
saying that one of the challenges that I
have in completing work and getting into
a good work Groove is that um especially
nowadays because of phones and so easy
to communicate with other people it's
not that they interrupt me it's that and
and this happened the other day I set up
my new office really nicely I'm living
in a very quiet place now it's like
almost completely
silent unless I'm playing music it's
really interesting or the coyotes
sometimes come around and start doing
their thing at night but completely
silent and I realized I was having a
hard time getting into a work Groove and
I realized that I felt compelled to
continue to reach out to people and then
I realize as you just provided your
answer to the last question that you
know there's probably something in me
that has a bit of a fear
of separation or abandonment from People
based on my own experience and I feel
very well supported by my friends and
co-workers these days very very well
supported I'm in a kind of Pinch Me
place around that and but I realize now
that what's happening in my mind is it's
not a challenge of getting into the work
it's a fear that if I spend a couple
hours really in that tight tunnel of
creation that
there might not be anyone there when I
exit it which is a crazy thought that's
a crazy thought but that's the anxiety
and I only realize that now yeah so
thank you great you know I trust that
you guys will be there when I when I
exit the tunnel and when there's a
deadline I have no choice but to jump
into that tunnel that that's actually uh
what helps deadlines really help me do
deadlines help you do you like deadlines
uh deadlines don't help me at the
beginning of a process they can help at
the end once the code's been cracked
usually when I start something I have no
idea what it's going to be um so it's a
very open process in the beginning and
if there's any sense of uh required
timing that would undermine the freedom
needed for it to be all that it could be
but once the codee's cracked and you
know what it is and it's all there and
you're just you know the you're dealing
with the fine points then um it can be
really helpful to have a deadline
as many of you know I've been taking ag1
daily since 2012 so I'm delighted that
they're sponsoring the podcast ag1 is a
vitamin mineral probiotic drink that's
designed to meet all of your
foundational nutrition needs now of
course I try to get enough servings of
vitamins and minerals through whole food
sources that include vegetables and
fruits every day but often times I
simply can't get enough servings but
with ag1 I'm sure to get enough vitamins
and minerals and the probiotics that I
need and it also contains adaptogens to
help buffer stress simp L put I always
feel better when I take ag1 I have more
focus and energy and I sleep better and
it also happens to taste great for all
these reasons whenever I'm asked if you
could take Just One supplement what
would it be I answer ag1 if you'd like
to try ag1 go to drink a1.com huberman
to claim a special offer they'll give
you five free travel packs plus a year
supply of vitamin D3 K2 again that's
drink a1.com
huberman a number of questions were were
sort of comments about what people
believe your process is and one of the
repeating themes there which I thought
was interesting was it seems that Rick
Rubin is comfortable with uncertainty
and the unknown yes that is true yes and
no yes I am comfortable with it because
I accept that's the way things
are that said when I start a new project
I always have anxiety because I'm
uncertain of what's going to happen
and I want it to be good now I know it
won't be done until I feel good about it
so in that way there is no um there's no
real pressure but I do still feel this
anxiety of I wonder what's going to
happen today I hope it's good you know
when you've worked with musical artists
let's say um how important is it to you
to know what challenges maybe even what
successes but certainly what challenges
they happen to be going through at that
period in
time put differently do you end finding
yourself playing therapist and guide and
um psychological SL emotional mentor to
artists you work with during the
creative
process or is that
separate uh if they're going through
something that's interfering with the
work anything that gets in the way of
the work is something worth discussing
our Focus they're together is to get the
work
done sometimes it ends up being more
therapeutic to allow that to
happen one of the questions that really
stood out to me in this vast list of
questions um involved a quote from your
last discussion on this podcast our last
discussion on this podcast um so I'm
going to read a little bit of it because
it's fairly long but um I found this to
be a really important question that we
should get into in a bit more depth um
somebody I don't know who said If you
happen to talk to Rick happen to be
talking to you um ask him this for me in
his
book in the section on self-doubt Rick
said quote one of the reasons so many
great artists die of overdoses early in
their lives is because they use drugs to
numb a very painful existence the reason
it is painful is the reason they became
an artist in the first place their
incredible
sensitivity if you see tremendous beauty
or tremendous pain where other people
see little or nothing at all you're
confronted with big feelings all the
time
these emotions can be confusing and
overwhelm and overwhelming excuse me so
this goes on for some pages and then
this person says and I think they're
speaking for many people when they said
this resonated with me personally and I
wonder whether or not this is something
that maybe you've experienced yourself
or that you just noticed about artists
in similar situations and what sort of
advice do you give the artists you work
with in order to embrace
those painful tones Within them and
transmute them into great work I've
definitely felt them myself I'm
unusually sensitive in the world I'm
wearing red glasses in here for a reason
um I live a very um protected monk like
life
because simulation gets in the
way uh of my ability to be where I want
to be so I tend to stay away from things
um and it it seems to be the case with
many
artists
um a desire
for nurturing their internal
life and if if the goal is to nurture
our internal life it it um it invariably
leads to
sacrifices did you do you spend a lot of
time alone as a kid I'm asking this
question I did yeah I was the only child
and I spent most of my time alone when
you talk about controlling this amount
and type of stimulation in your life to
protect that inner landscape does that
pertain to certain personality types
even voice types i' I've found it
various times in my life I love people
but um there there's certain voices that
just great on me and I can't be around
them I just can't be around them they
drive me it brings out but it just it's
like a cacophony inside I just feel like
I'm being asked to drink something that
tastes awful um does it does that
resonate uh I I try to curate the people
around me to be people I want to have
around me whatever that is whatever that
well you said you protect the inner
landscape but certainly you're not
averse to high-intensity stimulation
think last night we went to the aew and
by the way thank you for taking me that
was such an incredible experience it was
really fun it was really fun it reminded
me
of early punk rock shows where like some
of my first punk rock shows where I went
and just was like oh my gosh this is
exciting and scary and I love it yeah
and it felt loving too yes which is also
the community of punk rock that I
observed and have been blessed to be a
part of it's like I it's like there yeah
there's aggression but there's also love
and then there's romance and then
there's also um betrayal and there's all
the elements but there's still a sense
of like everyone wants to be here and
there's a sense of goodness behind it
all even though some of it was bloody
and violent yes so for you what what
does wrestling allow you to feel in
those high-intensity environments it
completely relaxes me because there are
no Stakes you know
nobody everyone's working together in
the show to protect each other no one's
trying to hurt anybody regardless of
what the story line is it's like a
ballet where there's a fight in the
ballet there's no um
there's no actual aggression of people
towards each other it's just the
opposite but you get to experience this
wildly Dynamic exciting
surreal theater
piece uh where people are doing these uh
gymnastic and acrobatic things that are
truly death
defying
um and it's fun and the the story lines
absorb you in a way where you know you
never know what's true and what's not Mo
you know we know wrestling's fake we're
told wrestling's fake but there's
something um legitimate about
it that seems to me more legitimate than
anything else the most
legitimate because it's the closest to
what the world's actually
like people don't always tell you what
they really think and when someone tells
you a story it might not really be the
true
story they may even think they may be
they may think they're telling you the
real story and that might not be the
real story we don't know we know so
little you know we we we experience
something and then we make up a story to
understand it
ourselves and then forever more when we
tell that story it was our version of a
of an experience but we don't know
that's what happened that was our take
on
it um wrestling is like that's what the
real world is
like because we when you watch wrestling
you never know what's true that's what
if you watch the news like you watch
wrestling and you never know what's true
it's more it would be more accurate you
you'd have a better sense of the world
if you took it all in like it was pro
wrestling I think we're in a place in
human history where people are starting
to feel that way about the media it's
also why wrestling's so popular you know
it's it's uh more popular than it's ever
been yeah that's interesting things like
UFC kind of gladiator like octagon
fights and wrestling are increasing in
popularity despite the fact that
supposedly we're evolving so I think it
reflects something both primitive and
evolved about the human brain yes right
primitive in the sense that yeah there's
some violence it's physical that's down
in the hypothalamus as we'd say no it
scratches that
itch
but they're actually protecting each
other you know it scratches that itch of
seeing the
Gladiators but it's like watching a
movie you know it's not they're not
really it's they're not really hurting
each other they get hurt but only
because the things they're doing are so
crazy I think in order to be able to
thoroughly enjoy wrestling one has to be
able to give up narrative distancing
just a little bit right narrative
distancing is this sense that this is a
story it's a movie it's it's not real
but there were moments like yesterday
the the jump off the top rope onto the
guy who SPL out on the ladder the ladder
breaks this was right in front of us it
couldn't have felt good no he walked
away he seemed fine yeah uh is but that
and then um there was a match between
two women where a woman put a metal
plate into her uh into the bottoms of
her suit and then ran in then jumped
onto the other woman and you know hit
her with the metal and then the metal
plate kind of slipped out and she was
walking around and everyone knew she had
cheated cuz you're not supposed to use
the metal plate but so it was sort of
exciting cuz she had done it exciting
cuz she had gotten away with it and then
at the same time exciting and upsetting
that the referee saw it but then didn't
call it this is like Twitter X this is
like Instagram this is like politics
this is like this is real life right
like seeing people get away with things
is so frustrating if you feel they
shouldn't have yeah that's all part of
it it's like uh it's a very uh accurate
representation of the world love it I
I'm it's it's weird because I never
would have thought I'd be hooked I'm
hooked it's like archery and
professional wrestling now it's like I'm
going to be busy guy in
24 I'm going to come back to this very
practical question and ask a different
question
first there are a few comments in here
that are just Priceless by the way so
wanted to point out that you're a Pisces
and so is
Einstein a couple of historical
questions I know you're not big on
answering historical questions um
necessarily maybe you are but I can't
help every time I see you asking a
question about the Ramones or asking a
question about Joe Strummer but I I like
this question first of all it starts off
I love Rick Rubin he's so fascinating
there's so many questions that start
that
way
on the podcast that you did with Joe
Rogan uh you talked about your
experience with Johnny Cash and seeing
him in a new light after doing
interviews for a book about Johnny or
something like that um the question this
person asked was from your present view
what was the most impactful moment or
moments from being with him and working
with him or simply do you recall a
moment working with Johnny Cash that you
particularly
enjoyed uh I enjoyed anytime I got to
spend time with him he was a really
Soulful
serious
shy quiet man incredibly knowledgeable
he knew a great deal about history and a
so much about music he knew every song
he didn't he may not have known modern
songs but he knew the history of
Music um really
well and there was just a a humble
honesty about him
that came through I think that the
strength of him as an artist was when he
said words even if he didn't write the
words if he told a story in words you
believed that
story so he had a a credible
gravitas and um he was great because of
who he was it wasn't his ability as a
singer it wasn't his ability as a
songwriter or although he was a great
songwriter and he was a great singer but
that's not why he was Johnny Cash He was
Johnny Cash because of the human
being underneath and anything that that
guy would have
done we would be interested in because
that's how much of a beam of light he
was on the planet it just happened to be
music just happened to be
music I love
that one question that came up a lot and
I I think I can understand understand
why which
is how does one convince themselves that
what they're doing and working on is
worth it and I think here we have to
Define worth it um and we can Define
that a number of ways but I think this
is a feeling that I hear people Express
a lot like how do I know if I'm on the
right path and I just want to remind
your earlier answer that you're pretty
comfortable with uncertainty yeah this
and the unknown and I think that's a
rare trait the question of worth it is
reliant on an
outcome we don't make these things for
an
outcome it's it's it's not the mindset
to make something
great the outcome happens you're making
the best thing you can make it's a it's
a devotional practice whatever happens
after
that happens and that part that happens
after it is completely out of your
control
putting any energy into that part that's
out of your control it's a waste of time
all it is all it does is undermine your
work your work is to make the best thing
you can so any thought you have about
outcome undermines the whole
thing let that one sink in I think
that's so important for people to hear
and I'll say it's okay to think about
outcome after you finished the thing
you're making once you've made it then
you can say hm what can I do to turn
people on to this but in the making of
it it's
premature which brings my mind back to
that diary entry like approach because
when you do a diary entry if you lie to
yourself you're going to get a lot less
out of it it's it's a ridiculous idea
lying in your diary entries it is well
it's so interesting because when you
learn how to do really good science and
I was fortunate to work with someone who
was truly committed to the truth and
accuracy she used to just say whenever
there was a scandal published like
someone fabricated data she was like
this is so crazy like like why would you
get into science you'd be if you want to
make you be better off going into
something else so clearly they weren't
those people who make up data were not
in science for discovery of Truth as
best we can understand it they were into
it for something else but it's the same
way you do you formulate a question then
a hypothesis and then you just go see
what is and what isn't and then
afterwards you decide well is this a
paper that's send to a top journal or a
mediocre Journal but you can't control
the outcome so it's very similar exactly
the same and and it you'll see it in so
many different aspects of Life Beyond
art it's it's I think one of the things
that was interesting that came up in
writing the book is it
started being about art and I came to
realize as I was putting the ideas
together that it seems like regardless
of what you do in life if you follow
these principles your life life will
probably improve you'll probably be a
better husband or a better father or a
better whatever it is it's
um it seems like the the art is an
outgrowth of it's why the subtitle is a
way of being it's like you
create yourself in a way in the world
where the things that you make are
tapped into something
deep but that comes from you being
tapped into something deep that's how it
work works so tapping into self
grounding in self not thinking about
outcome diary entry like approach to
creating
stuff seems to be the and I I think one
thing I'll I'll say to that because I
say tapping into self it doesn't come
from the self but you have to tap into
yourself because you're the vessel to
allow it to come
out everything in the vessel is coming
from somewhere
else it's not it's not your
creation you're the
um it's like you're the sculptor or the
you're the data an analyst where you're
taking these things from different
places that you've noticed some things
that you've noticed some things that you
don't know that you've noticed but you
did you know that's how we learned you
know we take in a lot of information
that we don't even know we're taking
in but the way we can take these data
points that are inside of us that came
from outside of us and create a
constellation that's what that's what
the artist job is but also that's what
we all do all the time and to get better
at it it's getting more in tune with
yourself and opening yourself to things
outside of um I'll say if you have a
narrow belief
system you'll have less information to
to work with less data points so being
open-minded and um allowing surprise to
be
surprised holding all of your beliefs
very
Loosely it's interesting because it the
way you describe this and from knowing
you as well it it seems that this whole
process is best served by having really
good boundaries like not
getting um foggy about what's about you
and what's about somebody else or about
what other people want or the world
wants but also having really good
antenna and being able to see what's
happening in the world you can't be
cloistered and and like this no um but
part of the creative process kind of
feels and looks like you you're in
you're in a tunnel but then you you have
to bring in from the outside I mean that
um so it seems like making these two two
separate compartments that you can
Bridge um seems important and healthy I
mean here as you mentioned it's a way of
being it's not just about creating
things that's also a healthy way to be
in the world because if you're
constantly getting pulled around by
everything emotionally and things are
upsetting you that's not good but if
you're just cut off from
everything that's not good
either do you cultivate that way of
being through these practices um or do
you think you've been there's something
about the way you're wired that you
started off that way it feels natural to
me it feels natural to me and I'll tell
you when I was younger I thought I would
live in New York City my whole life and
there was a time when I felt like having
that energy and noise around me felt
good now I feel best in the jungle or
the
forest I didn't decide that I didn't
decide what feels good you know it it
just happened so you're clearly willing
to update and adapt change your
nutrition change your city the way you
feel get new information update love it
you're a scientist AB well I don't know
anything again we start with I know
nothing we all know
nothing so if something sounds
interesting worth trying I'll try it see
does it work does it not work you know I
thought at one point in time I thought
veganism was a good idea I was excited
about
it and I did it for a long time I didn't
get the results I was hoping for I
didn't have Better Health I had much
worse health I had you know a tremendous
amount of weight gain and um I was very
ill through that diet but I didn't my
intentions were good how do you approach
resistance especially resistance in
other artists you work with you know
presumably people hire you they they
want to work with you they they do want
to work with you but I think what the
person is asking here is if somebody
you're working with is stuck like
they're stuck do you ask them to think
do you ask them to feel do you ask them
to take a day off do you uh do a Dennis
Rodman on them and send them to Vegas to
party for a couple of days because
that's what worked for
Dennis do you leave them
alone let them come to you I think
people are very curious about what those
sorts of interactions are like I think
it's always a case-by case situation it
really depends on the artist it depends
on the situation and um and usually by
the time that we're working together
any resistance they had in the past has
already been overcome usually we I'm
together with someone who we we make a
team with the idea of making the best
thing we possibly can and we'll both do
anything we can for that thing to be the
best it can it can be we're past the
resistance I noce you remain friends
with a lot of the people you've worked
with which is a great Testament to you
and your work and who you are I just
want to mention that that's not always
the case folks with uh other producer
artist relationships so it's worth
pointing out a practical question but I
think one that um is is worth asking is
uh do you handle the finances around
your work with artists do you have
someone else do like negotiations and
all of that kind of stuff I honestly
have no idea how it
works I have no
clue it see everything seems to get done
but I have no idea in the inner work of
any of it I try to I try to stay out of
as
much
um if it's not about making the
beautiful thing in the moment I don't
really want to think about it too much I
don't want to be involved in that aspect
there interesting when I was visiting
you this summer we had a really
delightful dinner conversation with one
of your other guests and at one point
probably due to me frankly the
conversation veered a bit into the
business realm and I'll never forget you
said in a very polite way that didn't
feel dismissive at all you
said let's talk about art
instead right like enough about business
let's talk about art instead and and in
that moment I don't remember that well I
gleaned a lot of gems from that visit um
I wasn't there to study you I was there
to hang out with you but I gleaned so
many gems treading water in the pool
some of the other practices we'll talk
about but I remember that and I think
about that in myself a lot in the
morning you know the emails and things
coming in and then I
think my purpose in life at this point
in my life is to collect organize and
disseminate health and science
information yes so that for me is Art in
this sense and anything else feels kind
of someone else can do that right
someone else can do you have a
particular gift and that you can take
complicated scientific ideas and explain
them in a way that all of us who are not
scientists or not um
medical students can understand and it's
really helpful and you do it in a kind
and loving way
where we get the sense that you care
that we understand you explain it in a
way that there's a a a care in it that
really speaks to us so thank you for
thank you for teaching us thank you and
thanks for the words that means a lot to
me that is indeed what it is for me I
want people to know the information
because I think it's so cool and so
important and they need the information
and it's not about me it's like I like
they have to know and you did it this
morning for this guy on the beach so I
he'll he'll see the light pun intended
I'd like to take a quick break and thank
our sponsor inside tracker insid tracker
is a personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and
DNA to help you better understand your
body and help you reach your health
goals now I've long been a believer in
getting regular blood work done for the
simple reason that many of the factors
that that impact your immediate and
long-term Health can only be analyzed
from a quality blood test a major
problem with a lot of blood tests out
there however is that you get
information back about metabolic factors
lipids and hormones and so forth but you
don't know what to do with that
information with inside tracker they
make it very easy because they have a
personalized platform that allows you to
see the levels of all those things
metabolic factors lipids hormones Etc
but it gives you specific directives
that you can follow that relate to
nutrition behavioral modification
supplements Etc that can help you bring
those numbers into the ranges that are
optimal for you if you'd like to try
insid tracker you can go to
insidetracker
docomond to get 20% off any of insid
tracker's plans again that's
insidetracker tocom
huberman do you prefer the WWE or the
aew Rick I love them both I love pro
wrestling pro wrestling is
great how often do you abandon an idea
or project like is there a is there a
pile of of journals with crossed out
ideas some place in Rick rubin's
basement I would say there there are
many ideas that have not yet come to
fruition but I wouldn't say I've
abandoned
any they it seems
like the ideas have a time when they
want to come to fruition and regardless
of what I think I don't get to determine
the
calendar the ideas come I can get
excited about it I can work on it and
then hit a wall nothing else and nothing
it just impenetrable and then there'll
be another project that just sailing
along easily and the universe is working
to help support that idea so I tend to
work where there's several balls in the
air at once and I don't fight
against
[Music]
um if the universe is not helping a
project I'm wey to fight with the
universe how many projects are you
working on right now or typically I it's
impossible for me to even say there are
so many there's so many ideas and some
of them are
in idea phase and some of them are in
mid you know mid-ming stage and some of
them are in the final you know final
detail stage there's always something
happening I'm always thinking about a
lot of stuff and some of it
is stuff that I get to share with the
world but some of it might be you know
remodeling a space or uh I'm always
thinking about some creative uh
puzzle I have to imagine that for you
when the
internet came to be that it must have
been really exciting because like me you
love foraging for information I used to
go to the library and Xerox copy papers
and I loved looking through the stacks
but frankly it was physically exhausting
and timec consuming and financially it
was hard for me at the time and then
you'd always get those copies where like
the book creas you know obscured uh that
the the text closer to the to the spine
of the book and you know I love PubMed I
mean like the world's at my fingertips
the world of research is at my
fingertips my goodness uh how do you
feel about smartphones and the internet
I mean to you does it feel like a like a
giant gift for your creative process or
is it an inhibitor it's it's both you
know I love that all the information is
at our
fingertips
and sometimes have having so much
information is
um it's hard to sort I'll tell you a
quick a quick story which was when the
music streaming Revolution happened I
was really excited the idea that all of
music is in my pocket now and I can
listen to any any song any album from
any point in my life or I get to hear
about something and it's all accessible
right now in this moment and I was
thinking at that time
I'm just going to DJ all I'm going to do
is DJ and I'm going to listen to
anything I can think of that I'm excited
about haven't heard the Talking Heads in
a while let's listen to Talking Heads
just how great that that freedom is to
have everything at your fingertips and
what I came to learn very quickly is I
don't want to DJ all day I love that I
have the ability to DJ all day I love
that when there's something I want to
here I can find it but I don't want to
have to do the work of pick everything
I'm going to listen to I like being
programmed to and I like the discovery
of somebody else playing something that
I wasn't expecting and getting to enjoy
that so now I do more listening to
either somebody's curated playlists or
uh online radio stations and I do less
picking music to listen to but I never
would have known that before because I
always thought well if I could listen
anything I want I want to listen to what
I want to listen to I didn't know that I
didn't want to have to pick it I love
the rare lie versions and um bsides and
whatever Z sides that one can find on
YouTube like the other day you sent me
just at random a a clip from I think it
was a
Japanese television show with the
Ramones opening up um and Johnny opens
up
with you're loud mouth baby you better
shut up and then they they
yeah and I it's the song I could have
heard anywhere else but it was the fact
that it was shot from
above that it was black and white and
that he adds this little riff at the
beginning you're a loud mouth baby you
better shut up and then just dives into
it that made it for me as a huge Ramon's
fan I was like yeah like you know I
think I did that in my kitchen yeah like
I was so hyped because when you go and
just listen to a
song that's recorded as part of an album
you're not not going to get those
additional
pieces back in the day and still now if
you went to a live show you might see
that and hear that and never forget that
but in that sense to me YouTube and and
the internet is like wow like it's this
AR Archive of gems that I I potentially
have been there maybe it was 79 I would
have been four years old yeah so you
know um anyway thanks for sending me
that clip loved it because you know how
much I love the rones but um things like
that I just think God the Internet is
just
amazing and so spectacular yeah and the
amount of lectures you could find on
YouTube are
unbelievable the the greatest thinkers
in the world I I don't want to say are
on YouTube because they probably didn't
post on YouTube but their material is on
YouTube and it's unbelievable you know
things from old films from the 50s and
60s it's all on YouTube yeah I've been
listening to Bible interpretation on
YouTube wow and there's just it's
interesting to hear different
interpretations from different
perspectives I would have never found
these people most of them are links
please yeah they're so good I'm I'm
trying to work through the Old Testament
start to finish now as a as a learning
and a practice and wow okay so the
question was are smartphones the chains
that bind us and prevent our
creativity um but I think you answered
that it's both a um a rocket ship to
creativity and a and a and chains to the
ground yeah and it's like all of it
tools it's like the tools don't make or
break your art it's just it's another
tool you can use it or misuse
it someone wanted to know and I would
like to know whether or not you have any
recurring dreams and what are your
thoughts on dreams and dreaming in
general do you write down your dreams do
you spend time thinking about them I've
gone I've gone through phases of my life
where I've written down dreams I'm not
doing it right now
um I think we can learn a lot from from
writing our dreams I tend not to analyze
in the moment but I've noticed when I've
kept a dream journal and looked at it
years
later these surreal things that made no
sense were all saying the same thing and
they were all very clear based on my
life experience at that time so it gives
us Clues as
to um what's actually going on the way
our subconscious is experiencing Our
Lives it's giving us a I don't know if I
would call them pointers um
Reflections would maybe be a better
word our mutual friend Paul kti um
believes that the unconscious or
subconscious is uh both used
interchangeably is the supercomputer of
the human brain that the
misconception is that the forbrain which
is involved in planning and context and
anticipation of outcomes Etc people
think that's the supercomputer but that
the supercomputer is the unconscious
that's Paul's belief
he's stated that very clearly on this
podcast and elsewhere and he believes
that in dreams the unconscious mind is
controlling more of the dialogue which
makes a lot of sense yeah but also that
the unconscious mind is constantly
trying to teach us things in the way
that we learn best so like my dreams for
instance are all analogies because
that's pretty much if people listen to
me talk on the podcast I often we use
analogy um and I'm very visual so it
will present things to me in visual
symbols so Paul said in terms of dream
interpretation that we would all be wise
to think about how we learn best and our
unconscious mind is trying to toss us
things in dreams to um explain things in
the way that we learn it makes sense and
I would say also
unconscious and our Instinct the way we
Act instinctually is a reflection of our
unconscious and as artists that's a
tapping into
that the instinct inct and the
unconscious is where the great ideas are
and then things that come from our um
intellectual selves are are much less
they have much less of a charge they're
much smaller ideas yeah I think uh the
the conscious mind and the intellectual
mind as you you're calling it are bound
to outcome in a big
way I'm going to inject a question of my
own
um I'm fascinated by the way you've
discussed people's real underlying
motivations and how that shapes their
creative process but also their career
um if you would be willing to talk a
little bit about the story of Andrew
Dice Clay that's the story that to me
captures it
best um Andrew Dice Clay uh was a
uh a comedian who told really offensive
jokes and his audience loved him for it
but the people who weren't his
audience didn't really understand it and
they vilified
him and he became a comedian because he
wanted people to love him he didn't
become a comedian to hurt anybody he
wanted to entertain people and while he
was playing to you know sold out Madison
Square Gardens full of
people newspapers would write terrible
things about
him and it really got to him and he
decided to change his artistic output to
try to make the people who didn't like
him like
him and when he did that it undermined
his whole
gift
and it just it seemed like things fell
apart I think he's in a better place now
I haven't I haven't seen him in a while
but I think he's in a better place now
and he's back
to uh caring less about the
reaction and in turn getting a better
reaction um because he's being pure
in what he thinks is
funny I liked him very much in fact I
thought he did a spectacular job as
playing um the female artist's father in
A Star is Born had Le Gaga and um Brad
Cooper he's a really good actor he's a
great actor yeah well
I really like the story about him
because it encapsulates so much that if
people can think about why they do what
they do they're going to avoid
pitfalls um
potentially um but how much time do you
think people should spend introspecting
about what makes them tick and why they
want to entertain or make jokes or um I
don't think it's a one-sized fit I don't
know that I could answer that
question is it true that that ad Rock
encourage you to give LL Cool J a chance
yes that is true ad Rock heard the demo
tape and insisted that I listen to
it love
that this is a kind of generic question
but I think it's good to put these in
every once in a while um what is your
advice to a starting comedian you know
these are the the sort of like I I
always think of these like uh you know
sophomore in high school kind of
question but that doesn't necessarily
mean they're bad in some sense that's
what makes it's such a great question
like what would your advice be to a
starting comedian be true to yourself
and not to listen to anyone there you go
um it would be a great book except it'd
be a very short book but you also make
it a very great book um book could be a
blank book could be you can just put all
the things that you want to put in it oh
man I'm working on a book now and I'll
tell you it's hard by the way I asked
Rick for advice about book writing um
because I'm been trying to write this
book for a while and he gave me this the
following advice so I'm injecting my own
question he said the sooner you can get
to a complete draft that you're happy
with or happyish with the better the
process will go so I'm working on
getting that complete draft yeah I would
say don't Focus too much on any of the
individual details until you have the
whole thing down and then you can focus
on all making everything better that you
want to make better don't get bogged
down in that at the expense of getting
through the
project your advice has really been
helping me by the way great I'm doing it
like diary entries great and I've kept a
diary for many years so that's somewhat
natural tell me a little bit about your
diary entries how long how long is a
diary entry sure yeah um a diary entry
is anywhere from like one to eight
handwritten pages single line spacing
going back and forth between I usually
start in all capitals and then switch
over to cursive as I speed up uh I've
been doing that since gosh since high
school School I've got a drawer filled
with them dated and everything and um
it's usually a process of just trying to
get something out of my system that I
feel is is like clogging me some
frustration with the outside world but
sometimes like this morning I journaled
uh in the room before you showed up and
I just was like I think I was riding
high off wrestling last night I was
marveling at how similar the Great
experiences of my life are now as they
were to every other stage of my life in
the sense that they give me this feeling
of like okay like they're these gems and
I'm of people you and others
and experiences and I'm finding them
like I'm experiencing them and reminding
myself that there there are long periods
in between those moments where things
feel kind of
like not empty certainly not empty but
but kind of frustrating in the sense of
like I'm busy and I'm dealing with a
bunch of things and things don't feel
smooth and um but I've been through
enough of these cycles that I
just I'm really learning to enjoy the
cycles and that was it and uh I and I
think the last line in my entry was
something like you know and you know and
I can't wait for more or something so
this morning is just a very positive
entry but sometimes you know I mean they
definitely some tear stained entries and
they definitely some entries where I'm
just so pissed I can barely get the
writing out but it's it's a process of
like getting that stuff out so then I
can lean into the day do you ever go
back and look at them I did the other
day because I recorded an episode on a
very particular type of journaling
that's supported by over 200
peer-reviewed studies which is called
expressive writing I can tell you about
it it's a process that was developed by
James pennebaker who is a professor at
University of Texas Austin and he had
his students
right as part of an experiment for 15
minutes a day for just four days
either consecutive days or a week apart
but about the same thing and the thing
that they're supposed to write about is
the most challenging upsetting or even
traumatizing experience of their life
and it shows that the data from over 200
studies show incredible positive shifts
in Psychology physiology immune system
function and ability to combat
infections I was so struck by the data
from this work that I decided to
dedicate a whole podcast episode to it
it'll probably be out by time um this
episode airs but um I haven't done that
one yet I'm going to do it it's a little
bit of a higher bar entry cuz it's like
okay I'm going to I hear that the first
day especially is pretty upsetting
because you're purposely picking
something really hard but
um yeah but most of the journaling I do
is just kind of diary like here's what
happened here's what's going on and my
biggest fear is that somebody would find
them but in preparation for that episode
about penne Baker I went and looked at
my journals was like what do I write
about and I realized they're pretty
autobiographical um sometimes about
troubling things but never before had I
written four times in a row about the
exact same thing interesting yeah yeah
pennebaker I think deserves a Nobel
Prize if you look at the data on this
compared to and I'm not disparaging
prescription drugs per se but like ssris
for
depression it's like at least as good a
treatment it's like zero cost stuff but
it you know and on and on you don't to
be careful I'll start giving the podcast
again now there were a number of
questions about quote unquote
entertainment and music
industry none of which unfortunately
were particularly complimentary of quote
the industry and I think this is
something that comes up a lot because
people often focus on the marketing the
personalities that may or may not be so
pleasant at times I'm sure there are a
ton of pleasant Personalities in the
industry too but the question is this
how do you deal with the and these are
their words Soul crushing anti- creative
aspects of the entertainment industry
and hold on to that sense of creativity
and love for the work I'm just focused
on the work I don't think of myself as
part of the um the entertainment
industrial
complex I just make the things I make
and then there are other people who are
good at figuring out how to sell them or
get them into stores or get them onto
services do you have a process of
capturing ideas like do you write them
down um and the reason this question
came up so many times I think is that a
lot of people feel like they get great
ideas right upon waking or while driving
or in the shower at random times and
they were wondering whether or not you
have any way of collecting and curating
your ideas prior to embarking on quote
unquote a
project uh I I write them I make notes
in my phone I do it all the time I don't
have a great way of doing it and
sometimes I'll make a note and then come
back to it later and have no idea what
it means do you make those notes uh by
writing or by uh like voice memo writing
that said voice memo might be a
something worth trying I've never tried
that how do you view money in
relationship to your work meaning how do
you place it in the constellation of
things related to a project you
mentioned earlier you let other people
do the negotiations
but money is just another form of energy
um H how do you place it in the in the
Contour of what you do I I don't I try
not to think of it at all and I because
I come from a punk rock background which
was like a do-it-yourself
background it was always more about the
idea and the execution of the idea with
whatever you could use to do it so if I
didn't have uh enough to go to a
professional recording studio then I
would find a friend who had a home
recording studio and recorded or
whatever it was or borrowing a drum
machine when I before I had a drum
machine I would always find ways to make
the things I wanted to make and
um I I can't remember a time where a
financial boundary got in the way of
making something and I see it happening
a lot around me and it um
I think some people look at it as the
money is what allows it to happen and I
think I I just see it as the ideas what
allows it to happen and then the
Ingenuity is figuring out how to do it
with you know by any means necessary
just got to make it whatever the that
version is it may not be the dream
version but whatever version you can
execute is the one for you to
make I can attest to the fact that I
launched my podcast in my closet in
Tanga Canyon yeah which felt felt
totally natural cuz I also come from the
skateboarding punk rock thing where like
wouldn't ever occur to me to like get a
professional studio built like we're in
now we had this one built for us but at
the time like of course you use a closet
because you just need a black backdrop
and you know I think starting from there
makes so much sense and you also realize
in the minimalist approach you know
anything added is just something added
so you don't really know what you need
if you start with a lot of stuff around
you yeah it's it can just be a
distraction I'm friends with Darren
aronowski who's a great director and his
first movie was called pie and he made
it for practically no money and it was
really well-loved and then the next
movie he made was also wildly successful
and he made it for very little money and
then he made this huge hundred million
movie and it wasn't it turned out not to
be a success that movie and it was a
case of where having more money didn't
help him tell a
story it's just one particular case
um and it's no rule to follow uh but
there is something about making the
version that you can make with the means
that you have that adds
something real to the project that may
be better than the one that has a lot of
money thrown at it I'm L that sink in
around a lot of online tutorials for
science have a lot of visuals but we
knew we wanted to do YouTube but also
just pure audio and it there's nothing
more frustrating than somebody talking
about something or somebody that you
can't see because you're just listening
to it um and the visuals were really
expensive to do right and in the end I
think if PE I firmly believe in the
classroom as well as via
podcasting if people can hear something
clearly enough and create an image in
their own mind of how they would
visualize it then it's in there for good
whereas just having people look at a
slide with with a bunch of beautiful
illustrations on it that does nothing
for retention of
material um so I think the minimalist
approach I think sometimes is really the
best one maybe it's always the best one
because it forces the better solution
like the in any
case I do realize I editorialized there
folks I entered the answering portion of
the not just the question asking
portion have you ever felt that
something was too obscure for mainstream
audience appeal to the point where you
did not release it never tell tell us
more if I like something someone else
maybe they'll like it I don't know how
can I judge how can I judge every I've
been
told with every new thing that I've done
it's a terrible idea and it won't work
every single time really every single
time Ghetto Boys LL Cool J beasty boy
Slayer Adele every one of them Eminem
every one of every time when I went from
producing rap records to producing
Slayer you can't do that you're you're a
rap producer it's going to be terrible
don't do it or then Johnny Cash you
can't do that you're a metal rap
producer you can't do that it's going to
be terrible don't do
it every single time still to this
day still to this day I was so excited
when you launched tetragramaton and it's
going so well I listen to every episode
I love the interviews I've been
fortunate to be on there twice I think
the second one is still hasn't been
released yet but I mentioned tetr Graton
because it just feels
so you like the ad read which I talked
about it during my intro but the ad
reads are amazing like I listen to the
ad reads over and over again because
they're so clever and they I don't know
they put me in a state I feel like I'm
watching I'm like I'm transported to as
if I was like born in the 1940s I'm
listening to television for the first
time mhm there's there's something there
like there's really something there it
it's it came out of solving a problem
the problem was uh when I decided to do
the podcast I had even recorded the
first several
episodes um a friend of mine said well
you're going to have to uh if you want
to have uh ads on the show to support
being able to do the show then you're
going to have to read the ads and I said
I don't really feel comfortable reading
as I don't think that's something I can
do
well I said I'm cool with the idea of
only advertising products I believe in
or that I use because that's if I get to
essentially promote something I'll do
that with things that I use but I don't
feel comfortable reading
it
um and he's like well you have to it's
going to be expected of you and it was
just an opportunity it was like uh okay
I understand it's expected of me what
can I do that's true to me that adds
something you know instead of it being
less than how can I make it more than
and it was just solving this problem of
needing a way to have an advertisement
that I didn't feel bad about and then
got inspired and had this idea and
started making them and now they're my
favorite thing in the podcast when it
when it in many podcasts honestly when
the ads come up I forward through them
when as a listener on tetr gramon when
it when a commercial comes on I always
listen to them it's so it's like a it's
a highlight and they make me
smile which is again and again I didn't
set out to do that I I just was trying
to solve a creative
problem so sometimes the um the
innovative ideas don't come when you're
looking for an Innovative idea it's just
there's this slot to fill this is the
way it's normally done I'm not
comfortable able doing it the normal way
how else can we solve this problem and
sometimes it doesn't just solve the
problem but it becomes an actual
feature yeah there's something about
that like solution
seeking
that is part of or at least is aligned
with the creative process right uh yeah
the ads are are extraordinary we were
listening to them in Italy I'm like play
that one again I love the way the guy
says the word he says or
something like but in but I can't do the
accent folks don't don't take what I
just said as as uh evidence of what the
like Australian accent that guy and the
Chimes in the background say is so
good you don't drink alcohol correct
correct have you ever had a sip of
alcohol uh I
had I drank alcohol once as part of a
class
experiment and had to mix all these
drinks and taste them and and um it was
a terrible experience but it was a it
was a requirement in the class I was
taking wow school was different back
then yeah or that school was different
yeah I think school was different we
used to prick our fingers and do our own
blood tests and science class I never
did it cuz I was always needle phobic
but that was definitely something that
was asked of us to do yeah you could
never get away with that now in a high
school
classroom the reason I ask about alcohol
is first of all I'm not the anti-alcohol
Crusader even though I did an episode
about alcohol which discouraged many
people from drinking more of
it
but I think for a lot of people the idea
of smoking cannabis drinking alcohol for
them in their mind is synonymous with
the creative process especially
music um for a lot of reasons that
people can
imagine I think it's remarkable and
impressive and worth spending a few
moments with you sharing with us you
know how is it that you were around all
of that you're clearly part of the part
of the
crew uh meaning you're part of the the
creative process presumably people
offered you alcohol drugs Etc but
something in you seems like resistant to
any kind of peer pressure and and as an
adult that impressive but to think like
you know like when I was 15 16 sure you
know I sort of regret it but yeah I
drank I I had my experiences and then
eventually stopped that but most people
are not good at like not drinking if
they don't want to drink ever or just
once from a high school class what what
was the internal narrative in your mind
um when that stuff was
around and what allowed you to just say
no I'm GNA I belong here but I'm not
going to do that it just was never
interesting to me and I I think maybe it
had to do with being an only child I I
never being an only child I think made
me less resistant to peer pressure
because I felt
more confident in who I was whatever
that was um just from being with my
being with myself and not with other
siblings I'm guessing I don't know if
that's right but that's my first my
first inclination is to guess that would
be the
case also I've always known what I like
and known what I don't like and know
there are things I want to try there are
things I don't want to try and I feel
very good about not doing something I
don't want to do I feel great about
it have you ever been curious about
psychedelics given that I'm very curious
I've never done it but I'm very curious
and I've been curious for a long time
there may be a time when I experiment
yeah there are two psychedelics in
particular that I find really
interesting one is uh macro dooc ibin
which I've done as part of a clinical
trial um and my understanding is it
reveals in a very intense and experient
itial way some component of the
unconscious mind and it allows for
plasticity and
rewiring of the brain that's permanent
if you come to some understanding
through the so-called integration it's
not without its risks the other one
that's really interesting that I've been
hearing more about and I have not tried
um and it carries some dangers as ibigan
which is 22 hours long and people
experience the world as normal with
their eyes open but when they close
their eyes they get a like high
resolution movie like version of Prior
experiences but they have agency within
those movies they can reshape their
reactions this is being used to treat
PTSD and
Veterans uh to great success um it has
some cardiac risk associated with it so
and it's not legal in the United States
it's not being explored in clinical
trials yet but the state of
Kentucky recently took I think it's $40
million from the um oxyc conton
settlement and it's is putting into iag
gain research interesting yeah so those
are the two that kind of spring to mind
you know kind of the classic psychedelic
experience I've also heard good things
about MDMA but I've never done that yeah
I have done MDMA uh as part again as
part of a therapeutic trial it's a
strong
empathogen um the danger with MDMA I
think is that
um if you don't stay in the eye
mask or if you're listening to music or
something you can easily get anchored to
some external cue and like see a plant
and be like I love plants and spend the
whole four to six hours thinking about
your love of plants which might be
valuable but I think the strong
introspective work um is best done with
a therapist there and you and the ey
mask and occasionally leaving the eye
mask and writing things down so you know
the reason I put that detail in there is
that um the Psychedelic experience is
very different with eyes open versus in
the eye mask with a clinician there
versus
recreationally and it's not just about
dangers versus safety it's also about
like it's a big investment and what one
stands to get out of it I think depends
on how much introspection you're willing
to do we won't be doing it this
afternoon there were at least a thousand
questions about attention deficit and
neuroticism people who feel like they
can't organize themselves and I thought
a lot about these questions and tried to
distill them into a single question and
eventually I did and it's this for many
people they associate the creative
process with
disorganization I think what's so
striking about you is that you embody
both the creative process but also a
strong sense of organization around
it like nothing
seems hairbrained or
know like random or halfhazard about
anything that you do and yet for a lot
of people who call themselves creatives
they'll say I'm a creative this that and
you look at the space they're in and
it's like chaos or they or their life is
kind of chaos not all of them
but is what I'm saying making sense
because I think why people Orient toward
you and one of the reasons for your
success with the creative process is
that you extremely organized but not to
the point of being
rigid are you willing to embellish a
little bit on that perception whether or
not it's accurate inaccurate I would say
there's a part in the process early on
where it is before it can get
organized where it's free and it's
playful and it can be
chaotic um it's just not the it's a
byproduct of whatever is happening it
it's not it's good because it's chaotic
and it's it it just happens to be
sometimes chaotic in that in that
experiment in the beginning where we're
really playing with this idea of of
having fun and creating stimulation and
seeing how it makes us feel and we try a
lot of we could try wacky things to get
there um but then when it happens when
you get that that feeling of like oh
this is interesting I haven't seen this
before
then it gets more um
controlled but it starts in a very free
place and I I don't know if I would
really use the word chaotic but it could
be I it certainly wouldn't be wrong I
would say more free would be the word
free like no um no
expectation and total immersion in like
an
improvisation that you're participating
in that can go wherever it wants to go
and you're cool allowing it to go
wherever it wants to go and sometimes
when it goes somewhere dangerous that's
when it gets interesting so the the I
can understand that that danger aspect
maybe that's why I like pro wrestling I
don't know but there's something about
when you get to this these edges where
this is not for
everybody it can get very
interesting speaking of
um stuff that's not for everybody and
that to some people might have been
shocking I remember hearing Ghetto Boys
for the first time and like whoa like
they're taking certain things pretty far
when you're working with an artist and
they venture out into that place where
things are like maybe even a little
shocking what is that feeling for you
internally like is it how do you
distinguish between shock value for its
own sake and something that's really
opening up a new creative Avenue or
Insight like like how do you do you
recall the first time you you heard like
Bushwick and those guys do their thing
yeah what what was your internal
narrative I can't believe it I can't
believe what they're saying it's really
um pushing the boundaries of what anyone
has said in this music before it had
switched because the the original in
originally in rap there was a lot of
boasting
about themselves
bragging and then we got to uh the
message happened and there was some
social
commentary then there was gangster rap
and then the Ghetto Boys took a version
of gangster rap and turned it into
horror rap which was much more graphic
than gangster rap gangster rap was
talking about a um
um a real life
situation whereas the Ghetto Boys took
it into horror movie
territory it was more
fantasy um but it seemed really scary at
the time in the way that you're scared
at a great horror movie do you like
horror movies I don't do you like
monster movies where you know it's not
real like it's
impossible uh as opposed to horror
movies where you know
it's um you know people getting killed
by another human like stuff that could
happen in the world versus um you know
monsters and zombies and that kind of
thing I don't think I really like either
of them very much I like things that
make me feel good I don't really like
adrenaline you know I don't like to be
excited for some
reason in
audio I like something that makes me
excited but in visuals I tend not to
like things that make me excited
M interesting and you're able to kind of
clean yourself of experiences easily
right like it seems like if you listen
to something it's really shocking you
don't carry that shock to your sleep or
to the next day like it doesn't trouble
you but a movie can can impact me like
there was a movie called Melancholia
that I saw years ago Lars vont Trier
movie and I thought it was a very
beautiful movie but I was in a bad mood
I would say for 3 months from the time I
watched that movie on it just like did
something to my brain that didn't feel
good and it couldn't snap out of it so
interesting there there are a few movies
that have done that to me the movie Blue
Valentine which has done really well
um which is with Ryan goling and someone
else where um it's a relationship I
won't explain what happens in The Arc of
the relationship but it just like the
movie Haunted me there's one scene where
he's wearing a misfit shirt and I was
like I like the and that's a
particularly good scene where he's
singing to her um but the rest of the
movie just brings about such feelings of
like just how hard life can be sometimes
and how misguided people can be in
relationship and it it's interesting how
movies can just kind of embed in us it's
not pleasant I don't want to talk about
it
anymore there were a number of questions
asking about how you consume information
in the world related to what's happening
in the world like where do you get your
news from you and I talk about this a
lot how do how do we know what to trust
these days um did should we have ever
trusted the news or is is it less
trustworthy now like where do you get
your information about what's happening
in the world and stay AB breast of like
world affairs I I honestly I don't feel
like I know anything about it you know I
um I tend to look at it all like
wrestling so if the story is good I
might
be more interested in the story but I
still don't hold much uh belief that
that story is
true yeah I don't know what to believe
anymore
uh I was asked to comment on a
particularly well-known person who's not
considered very Savory by a couple
news Avenues in the last couple of years
and um I don't know how people had in
mind that I would have knowledge about
this person and and I gave zero
information to these news outlets and um
nonetheless they they they didn't
publish quotes from me but they they
publish things that I know to be
completely false and they know to be
completely false so I I was just struck
by the fact that like in scientific
publishing that would get you you'd lose
your job forever well at one point in
time you would have lost your job now I
don't know if that's true if you lose
your job cuz we see it happening a lot
right yeah it's wild have you ever read
anything about you that's not true oh
yeah oh yeah okay so based on that
absolutely I mean some of it is playful
stuff like on Reddit and now they're
flagged as as play they have a little
flag that they can put as you know
comedic or something but oh sure I mean
things not just taken out of context but
things like
completely wrong like just like that I I
don't even know where people get this
stuff from I keep waiting for the thing
I'm going to see that says that I'm dead
yeah that'll be that'll be the moment so
based on that experience why would you
believe anything you read about anyone
else you you you get to see
firsthand that there are just stories
just not true and presumably you've seen
things written about you that are not
true absolutely right absolutely right
and artists I know friends of mine they
write things about him I know it's not
true
wild what do you think about the state
of play and is the experience of being a
parent and having a young child has that
allowed you more more opportunities for
play and to see through the world
through childlike lenses in uh greater
capacity or is it you
know just separate from your creative
process I would say I'm fairly childlike
all the time I try to
stay as uh
open the beauty of childhood is that you
don't know you haven't been
um indoctrinated
yet so you you see things and you have
wonder about them and it's a great
feeling that feeling of
Wonder and now when someone I I'll tell
you a story this is a a true story my
friend Owen came over one night in the
middle of the night and he had just seen
um luminescence in the water for the
first time and he had didn't know what
what it was and thought he was having
mystical experience and he was so
excited like you won't believe what
happened the the waves were like there
was light everywhere it was so cool i'
never saw anything like it and I said oh
yeah that's uh luminesence and I
explained what it was and it destroyed
the magic for
him he was really having a childlike
magical experience and I destroyed it by
telling them the science behind
it I try to live in a world where I can
experience what he experiences and I
don't let the story
ruin what's I allow the
possibility to go past what I'm told the
story is that that things can be even
wilder than the rational
explanation for me learning the
reductionist science behind something to
me adds depth and Beauty but then again
I realize I'm
I've been indoctrinated into the the
field of science so the Matrix they call
it the
Matrix this is one I didn't understand
but I'm going to assume that you
understand because it has to do with
people you've worked with if Rick had
casually dropped that the Ramones named
themselves after the fake last name Paul
McCartney used to check into hotels
during Beetle Mania would that have
blown Andrew's mind that's a kind of
weird question I guess the question is
is it true that the Ramones Nam
themselves after the fake last name that
Paul McCartney used to check into hotels
during Beetle Mania um I don't know that
I don't know if that's a true story I do
know that Paul McCartney used the name
Paul Ramone when checking into hotels
but I don't know if that's where the
Ramon's got the name got it and here is
how rumors turn into quote unquote facts
on the internet so we and also maybe the
Paul raone story is not true either but
that's story I've heard right that
reminds me and and I think this is an
important case in point that there's a
what I consider a very famous photograph
of you Johnny Cash Joe Strummer and
Henry Rollins mhm you're wearing a dead
Kennedy shirt the four of you are facing
one another and I love that photograph
because of who's in it um and I
remember hearing a rare track from
Strummer and the mescaleros called uh on
the road to rock and
roll um and then for some reason
probably because my phone is tapped into
my
brain I was served up a video on social
media of Henry Rollins telling the story
of that Gathering of the four of you
where Rollins is describing the story of
of uh Joe Strummer leaning
into Johnny Cash and saying hey I wrote
a song for you it goes on the road to
rock okay and I remember coming to you
and saying Rick guess what remember that
photo you're like I remember the photo I
said yeah Rollins has the story of what
was happening in that moment and I was
so excited and you said you said yeah I
don't remember that it might be true it
might be true but it might be entirely
made up also yeah and we're not calling
Henry a liar but Henry I I I believe hry
I believe Henry remembers that story and
that was his experience that was not my
experience or I don't remember it being
my experience but who knows anything
could have been
said it's true anything could have been
said like it it had as much to do the
fact that I don't remember has as much
to do with whatever I was thinking about
when that happened and the story that
Henry told had as much to do with what
was going on in Henry's head when it
happened we have no idea you know it's
we have no idea do you remember somebody
shooting the photograph I do not I'll
put a link to that photograph on the
Internet it's a really incredible
Gathering of phot I've seen the photo
but I don't remember it being shot I'm
looking for a high resolution version of
that photo if anyone can find me one
I'll be happy to compensate you
well there were a lot of questions about
your daily routine people love this the
morning routine the daily routine and
while
I have to believe that everybody's
necessary routine is quite different
from the next um if you wouldn't mind
just giving us a sense of like the first
couple hours of your day what that
typically looks like when you're like
not traveling and you're settled into to
a place uh it's different depending on
the place that I'm in but typically it
involves waking up going out into the
Sun as naked as possible to start the
day um I try to take slowly um wake up
slowly
and probably within an hour of that I'll
leave the house and go for as long of a
beachwalk as possible or if I'm in a
place where there's a the gym several
days a week I'll go to the gym instead
but some I'll do some
activity I would say about an hour after
waking up sometimes it's an hour and a
half sometimes it's less depending on
the place I'm at I also might do
stretching before I go on the walk and
do um just several stretches on yoga
mats on the floor or uh with foam
rollers or balls or some different
things I don't start my day until those
things are out of the way I try to avoid
um any work related anything now that
that said if a thought comes up that I'm
excited about I'll note it I won't um
avoid thoughts but I tend not to engage
in
any work until probably 11:00 11 a.m.
would be the soonest and in and some
days not until 1:00 and then I do f
focused work
until maybe
6 and then I spend the rest of the
night
uh trying to wind down out of work mode
so 1 p.m. to 6:00 p.m. are really the
peak probably quote unquote work hours
yeah could be 11 too like today we
started here at 11:00 and that felt like
I felt like I'd be good by 11:00 and I
already did my my morning walk I had the
argument on the beach I I was in the sun
I was in the hot tub I had a whole whole
morning
already and then what does your evening
wind down look like in terms of the
space that you're in uh or trying to
create and your internal landscape well
it's only red
light um I'm usually wearing from the
time sun sets I'm wearing red glasses
I'm in a space with only red
light I'm
uh
99% of the time home with my
family
and we
talk I might watch uh wrestling or a
documentary with red glasses
on um we eat dinner together or we eat
dinner in shifts depending on how it's
working but we're all we're all
together and I find something to occupy
my mind that
gets me out of the workday that said
sometimes the ideas still flow and I'll
note them but I avoid I avoid any kind
of a work phone call or um anything
that's stimulating or that will get me
thinking about
it I aim for Sunset and then I'm usually
in
bed I'm usually in bed by
10:
and um and fall asleep within 15
minutes your relationship to light is
fascinating the sunlight piece makes a
lot of sense and will make sense to the
listeners of this podcast we haven't
done too many episodes but we will do
more that covers the trying to avoid
bright light exposure in the evening um
you're wearing the red uh lens glasses
now even though it's the middle of the
day that's because we've got these
bright lights around us correct and have
you found that limiting your bright
artificial light exposure in the evening
has benefited you and in what ways
absolutely and and once you've done it
once you've changed and avoid like
looking at screens or my you know my
phone turns red at
night when I see someone else's phone if
someone comes to
visit
and their phone lights up at night it's
blinding and it's so disturbing
and for them that's normal they're in
this
heightened blown out place all the time
I'm staying at neutral I'm staying at at
the the the more
natural how how the world would be if
man didn't create all of these uh these
loud things loud loud um loud devices
yeah I've switched my phone thanks to
your input and we will have released a
clip on this um by the time this episode
airs on the triple click approach to the
phone that you can put in very easily um
to allow it to go from regular screen to
red screen at night so that you don't
have to go into the settings each time
you just triple click U we'll provide a
link to that um explanation and Rick
taught me that when I was over in Italy
everyone would in his home turned to me
and uh said wait your phone is so bright
you got to do the red light thing I said
I don't know how and it taught me that
so it's a very useful trick um have you
noticed a difference since looking at
huge positive difference I sleep better
there are great data now because of
course I go then and find the data that
um you know for shift workers people
that have to be up at night working if
they put them under red light the amount
of cortisol at that time is suppressed
which is great um as compared to when
they're under bright artificial lights
without red lens glasses or if they're
in red lights it's far far more
beneficial less cortisol you want
cortisol High early in the day viewing
sunlight early in the day increases it
by at least 50% then you want it to
taper off uh and on and on I heard
something recently which is going to
make a lot of sense one thing that's
happened in the last 30 years which may
at least partially explain the Obesity
crisis is
that calories which are depleted of
nutrients micronutrients are very cheap
now see they're very cheap cheap to get
calories but they aren't nutritious
calories in addition there's been a
change in lighting technology so that
blue light photons are very cheap like
when I was a kid they my parents would
say turn off the lights it's costing us
all this money now it's very cheap to
keep the lights on in a home the heat is
a different story but with respect so we
have a lot of cheap photons so I think
of blue light as cheap photons not the
good for you photons not nourishing
photons that's great and consuming
calories too often or at the wrong times
of day we know is bad for you consuming
photons in the wrong form at the wrong
time of day bad for you and I think
those two things combined plus all the
downstream negative Cascades can largely
explain the Obesity and in some sense
Mental Health crisis interesting yeah so
just a there I editorialized again I
realized that we're trying to shift the
ratio to more Rick less Andrew but he
can't help himself he can't help himself
and Rick indulges me so actually there
were a number of questions in here that
asked me you know how has Rick helped
you you and I I'm refraining from
answering those because this is people
want your answers for them but I I do
all the things that Rick's referring to
I'm not wearing red lens glasses now but
I have changed a lot of my health
practices Andor sought out science to
test whether or not some of the things
that you've been doing for a while make
sense and indeed in every case they've
made sense I'm not just saying that
because because you're here but you and
I do a lot of the same things yeah we're
we're interested and if it didn't work
we'd probably stop doing it eventually
right it's like we're testing things
right and I do believe that what starts
out is crazy like Mike mener stuff of
low volume weight training with heavy
weights it works so much better than the
high volumes all that stuff is being
shown to be true in these peer- reviewed
trials so you know that's the nature of
science it often comes science often
follows the practitioners by many
decades
MH you know it doesn't get there first
because it's a slower more iterative
process but some people need to see
those Clin iCal trials to feel
comfortable doing something I think the
creative process is uniquely separated
from academic science and academic
scholarship in a way that I think has
really benefited it I mean can you
imagine if the Ghetto Boys had to get a
degree in music theory in order to do
what they do they wouldn't be the Ghetto
boys right or Slayer they would not be
Slayer yeah or Public Enemy yes or Adele
yes or Eminem right it's it's almost by
virtue of the fact that there is no
degree for that yeah per se that allowed
them to do what they did right yeah
absolutely so what are your thoughts on
schooling and higher education or just
education I mean you were at NYU when
you launched your record label you
graduated NYU I um what are your
thoughts on getting a a quote unquote
formal
education uh it seems like an obsolete
idea I think maybe there was a time
where it would have been helpful and
maybe depending on the if the thing that
you want to
study um can only be learned in an
institution maybe it would make sense
but I think the real world um getting an
internship or a um finding the right
mentor and going into the whatever the
thing is that you're interested in
learning about learning from people who
do it as opposed to uh the the system I
think
I think might be more a better use of
your
time the creative process doesn't exist
in a
vacuum and relationships are a huge part
of life one thing that I've heard you
say and that certainly I've been working
to internalize is this idea
that whatever relationships one has in
their life romantic relationships or not
married or not kids or not
that the ideal circumstance is where
one's work is the most stressful part of
their life yes can you tell us more
about that yeah the the home is the um
the safe place from which you can go out
and be a warrior and do all these great
things and these crazy things you know I
have
um I'm fearless when it comes to Art I'm
not Fearless when it comes to
life life is my relationships
art is where we can do these crazy
things and have fun and um
try extreme things and see what happens
and it's a say that's a safe place to do
that because it's it's just expression
it's not
um the things we make don't have to
represent who we are they're just the
things we make and that's a point of you
it's like this is interesting to me in
this moment check it out that's all it
is may have a completely different
feeling tomorrow was in a
relationship it's it's longterm
hopefully and it's it's as long term as
it's a productive relationship where
everybody's getting what they want from
that relationship everybody's needs are
being met and everybody cares enough to
meet each other's
needs I've always admired how rational
you are about relation ships and this
notion that like if everybody isn't
being honest there's no relationship
actually not it's a bad relationship but
there's actually no relationship no
because if you if
you if someone's not telling the truth
then each person is experiencing a
different understanding of the
world they're living in two different
worlds so they're not they're never Act
actually
together when you're experiencing a
different world so unless you can you
don't have to agree I'm not saying you
have to agree on everything but you have
to be truthful in saying this is how I
see it and your partner is clear
in yes this is how I see it or no this
is how I see
it you're on the same you're on the same
page even even in disagreement but it's
real it's you're you're being who each
of you are being who you are for and
with the
other but if you're not opening yourself
up in that way to your
partner you're in a different world they
have an idea of what's Happening that's
completely different than what you have
an idea of what's Happening that's not
that's not being together no
masks
no no it's the it's the same as what
when you said earlier about lying in
your
diary you'd only be doing a diservice to
yourself lying in a relationship would
only be doing a disservice to
yourself Mike Ness of Social Distortion
as a song called cheating at solitire
which seems like an appropriate title to
mention right now lying in the diary
cheating at solitire yeah it's
ridiculous doesn't make any sense no
you're not you're not actually playing
the game do you know what I mean if
you're cheating at it you're not
actually playing the game the whole
point of the game is the game if you
cheat at it you're not playing the
game do you have any mustre books for
people I'll I'll throw one out Rick's
book on the creative act um a way of
being uh but in addition to that
book what are some books that you
recommend to people for stimulating
thought or for or um I don't know Health
purposes or things that you found
particularly beneficial in book form my
favorite book about meditation is called
wherever you go there you are I love it
and I just got sent the 30th Anniversary
Edition which is completely Rewritten I
have not yet read the re the Rewritten
version but I love the original version
and I know the Rewritten version I'm
guessing the the Rewritten version is
just more refined and even better such a
great book that book was given to me
when I was about 14 and a half uh when I
was um released from a particularly
uncomfortable nonv voluntary um uh State
of Affairs and one of the things that I
remember about that book that helped me
through so many years of life and I have
to go back to is this mountain
visualization
meditation being a mountain MH I don't
know why it was so helpful but goodness
was it helpful for me it's a beautiful
idea it's a beautiful
idea yeah I don't know why I thought of
that just now but I'm going to go back
and read
it do you think that
there's genetic epigenetic family
lineage stuff unrelated to genetics that
leads us to create things that are
really about like our ancestors you know
the for instance um is it possible that
uh let's take let's take Johnny Cash for
instance or an artist that you worked
with more recently Chili Peppers that
when they got together to make
music that something from Anthony's
Family line was being transmuted through
him into into the songs uh is that
happening do you think that we can work
out and and include things that are
Generations far back enough that we
don't we don't even really know what
happened to them I mean it's coming
through in our genes I think it's
certainly possible but I I don't think
we can know and I don't think it's
necessarily even helpful to know it just
is one of those mysterious things I
don't think we know why we do many of
the things we do and it's just another
example of that and that's a possible
Theory to explain why we do the things
we do maybe but there may be another one
it maybe uh UFOs are controlling us I
don't know do you know what I'm saying
it's it could be anything
there are people on the internet that
think it's UFOs that are controlling us
could be I don't I wouldn't um I
wouldn't disagree with that more and
more evidence is coming out that you
know that uh unidentified flying objects
might might actually be a documented
phenomenon by the US government I I
haven't looked into it yet but I
wouldn't be
surprised when you were on this podcast
before and on several other podcasts you
mentioned that you don't play music at
least at least not routinely you don't
play an instrument um that you have
limited knowledge of how a soundboard
works so when you're listening to
artists are you listening for something
or you're staying open for something
that you might hear like that that will
trigger a certain state in you that you
recognize I'm open to just see what's
happening like I I feel what's I I
listen and recognize is this making me
Lean Forward am I curious to see what's
going to happen next is the thing that
happens next different than what I
thought was going to happen next that
could be interesting you know I listen
to a lot of music when it doesn't do
what's expected that's really
interesting especially if it sounds good
if it
works um so I'm just open to
experiencing what it is and I'll say
something funny about it which is this
this will sound um mystical I don't
understand it but often you can tell a
lot about the piece of music you're
going to listen to based on the first
sound you hear like the first
moment it's not about what node it is
it's not about what instrument it is
it's
uh
intention in the performance and that
performance could even be a
machine the way
when something
starts sometimes there's this feeling of
oh this is going to be good just out of
the B the
downbeat can't explain
it reminds me of
dating uh and you know
within half a nanc like this is going to
be a fun night this be interesting night
this person's
interesting or okay this is not a night
to continue continue right I don't know
there's something and and it's not
what's said necessarily or even how it
said just it's a it's a feeling I know
that depending on how I'm feeling I'll
avoid listening critically to something
if I'm not feeling well if I'm if I
don't feel like I can be completely
there and
open I'll not
listen I I
know I I know I want to really be there
for the thing that I'm uh listening to
do you inform people if like hey I'm not
here today like I'm I can't sometimes
yeah
sometimes as somebody who has never been
part of the music production process how
long does it take like for an album like
let's throw out an artist you've worked
with like you worked with Eminem how
long did that you did some songs on that
album or the whole album I did some
songs so
did he come in with those written and
then you guys work together on those
songs how long was that a week a month a
day I think we were together for several
weeks it's been long enough now that I
can't remember the specifics but there
there is no rule of how that works and
sometimes things come together very
quickly an album can be made in the
weekend and some albums are years in the
making when it's years in the making
it's rarely
every day for years in the
making it's usually more episodic but
there is
something both versions are very
interesting and it's something that
comes out almost fully formed very
quickly has particular energy and then
something that's made over
[Music]
time can have all of those individual
moments all the changes that happen
within you over that period of time
those can all be reflected and be the
difference between a daily diary journal
and reading three months it's different
they're two different things can't say
one's better than the other they're just
two different things so some projects
are more like a Year's diary and some
are more like a
weekend and same you know you watch a
movie some movies the movie story takes
place in 24 hours
and sometimes it's a person's lifetime
one's not better than the one's not a
better method than the other it's
whatever suits the
work speaking of your work with Eminem
but also with Jay-Z and with BC boys and
others you are featured in a number of
the videos you show up in those videos
whose decision was that and um what are
your thoughts on music videos I remember
when music videos first came out the
whole MTV era and just think like this
is so cool I can see the artists see how
they're dressed I love the like the
crazy Styles and all of that that
accompany the music two questions one
whose decision was it to be in the
videos because producers often are not
included in the videos it would always
be if the artists asked that' be the
only reason I would be there and two
what are your thoughts on music videos
and the idea that then it puts a very
strong visual to the the song whereas
were there not to be a video people just
imagine something based on what they're
hearing and hearing
alone they're two different they're two
different things there's not a better or
worse there's sometimes where the video
makes the song better and
there's often the case where the Poetry
of the
words um if you close your eyes and
listen to what the words
are as a listener you get to participate
in that in creating that world in your
head
so sometimes photographs can tell us too
much information it's too leading it
limits the story to just this Photograph
the photograph tells you much more than
the words the words can be interpreted
in many ways and then we each get to
have that experience it's something in
the book that I was uh cognizant of in
picking the words was never to be
specific to the point of where the
reader doesn't get to participate in
this act so it doesn't tell you what to
think it's an invitation to think it's
an invitation to say Where am I in
this what's my version of this it's not
about anyone else it's about the reader
and that was
um it was from the beginning that was
always part of the
um my understanding of what I thought
would be the most
helpful the cover certainly embodies
that that it it's not clear exactly what
the cover design is quote unquote
supposed to be it's open to
interpretation interpreted as you wish
and different people see different
things let's get current what what are
you working on now that you're excited
about if you can share let me see what I
can and can't share be broad categories
of things too but okay uh I'm working on
a couple of um documentary projects that
I'm excited
about and some albums that I've been
working on over time are are coming out
um one is a incredible singer guitar
player named Marcus King his album's
about to come out uh the gossip is a
band that I made an album with 10 years
ago and we just made a new album or we
made an album Maybe 18 months ago and
that's coming out now
um those are the first ones that come to
mind is the documentary process fun for
you and how how do you approach
that uh I watch a lot of documentaries
to learn what I don't want to
do I don't think I've been inspired well
maybe some cases where I get inspired by
what I'm seeing but more often I see
things and I say okay these
documentaries all have this format so I
know I don't want it to be this
format um it's more of a ruling
out and it's fun to find new
ways that
reveal different
information than the standard format
allows it's interesting to me I we'll
see if anyone else cares you have a
unique approach to podcasting uh first
of all what are your criteria for who
you invite on as a guest
and second um what do you have in mind
when you sit down and
podcast um I have some ideas about how
you're going to answer but I think it's
important that uh I not inject and that
uh I think people are interested in this
even if they don't want to podcast
because I think it it gets to the
process of something that you're doing
now and how you're doing it now yeah um
I didn't set out to do what I'm about to
tell you I didn't set out to do this but
it's something that after I started
doing it I came to realize it it's an
interesting thing and I actually learned
this from listening to your podcast it
was actually Lex's podcast with you and
I was listening to the podcast and I
know you know Lex and I know you guys
are friends
and both of
you in addition to you talking to Lex
you're talking to the audience and Lex
in addition to talking to you talks to
the
audience and the a audience was a
participant in your
conversation and I realized that in at
the tetraman
podcast it's different than that it's
more of an
intimate personal like the interview
with you that hasn't come out yet that
was me talking to
you with
no I certainly didn't have any idea that
anybody else was going to hear it other
than yes someone else is hear it but
that's not what this is this is I was
asking you the questions I was
interested in and I wanted to learn as
much as I could and if you said
something either that I didn't
understand I'd ask you to explain it or
if you told me a story about something
that sent me on a tangent that would I
want to know more about this left side
of what you said or the right side of
what you said I would ask but only
following my own
interests so it has a an intimacy it's
turned into when I if if I listen to a
tetr gramon podcast it sounds like I'm
overhearing a
conversation a personal
conversation
and it it has turned into parts of
certain decisions we' made like having
there's music at the beginning and then
you hear the guest more often than not
is in the middle of a story and it's
almost as if you've walked into a room
and people are in this deep conversation
and you're just sitting on the side
quietly and hearing this conversation
and it's a a real moment that's
happening there and it's just different
I can't say it's better I can't say it's
worse can't say I don't know what what's
interesting about it but something about
it's interesting to me and when I listen
to it I feel a different kind of an
intimacy
um and again it wasn't premeditated this
is after the fact I'm looking back and
understanding oh this is what it is this
is why this is
different yeah the podcast that I did
with you on your podcast when I was
featured as I guess the second time I I
completely forgot that we were
podcasting it was also good we'd had a
few
days together overseas there we're in a
very kind of isolated environment that
helped me get out of the mode of there
are listeners yeah there's no there's no
sense of performance involved it's it
couldn't be more casual and the reason I
chose not to film it is because the
nature of lights and
cameras make it harder to forget that
you're doing it
so I aim for it to be as natural an
experience so that you can have the
conversation that you really would have
if there were no lights and cameras not
that not that we want to reveal anything
it's just it's a level of comfort and
openness where you're talking to
somebody you like and it's you're
enjoying the conversation and that's so
you I just have to share that you know
the first time we met in person you and
I had facetimed a number of times
previous to that but the first time we
met in person came over to your house we
ended up doing sauna and cold and I was
going through a particularly challenging
time in my life I mean it had really
just hit me square in the face and I
remember saying Hey listen I I don't
know if we could talk about this but I
just opened up about all of it and
that's the moment when like we would
have become friends anyway but that's
where things really took off because I
kept apologizing at the end I I'm so
sorry and you said no no this is
actually what we're supposed to do yeah
and you know I'm feel very grateful that
we've remained close friends ever since
and that catalyzed a lot but I think
that one of the things I love about
podcasts not just podcasting but
podcasts is that the really effective
podcasts like yours like Lex's like
Rogan like Rich
R Tim Ferris they really reflect the
love and passion that the person has for
that kind of conversation I mean I can
certainly say this about my podcast I
I've been learning organizing and
distributing information since I was you
know you know six years old MH so my
podcast is just that you you like real
conversation and real things that are
unb barriered by like the idea that
maybe someone's going to listen and how
will it work out just like we talked
about earlier and you answered the
questions that way and I think Lex likes
Lex's form of thing and Joe is doing his
form of thing and I think that's to me
one of the great gifts of podcasting if
anyone wants to know how to create a
successful podcast quote unquote
successful it's have the kind of
conversations and talk about the kinds
of things you really love like Cameron
Haynes has this lifr run shoot podcast
where you go to his house you do a
workout then you go for a run and then
he teaches you archery and the reason
it's so effective is that he loves
lifting running and shooting and then he
and he loves teaching people that so at
the end of the day you're sitting down
talking about a great day that embodies
everything that he's about and and the
person learned and like I couldn't do
that podcast I can go on as a guest and
I loved being a guest but I think that's
the message and it brings us back to
what you were talking about earlier and
throughout today's discussion
is that if you're thinking about how
it's going to land how the hell could it
ever work yeah it's just a different
thing I had a conversation yesterday uh
for the podcast with Daniel kuuya who
I've never met before incredible actor
and beautiful human being and we
probably talked for about 3 hours and it
was a deep conversation and I feel like
I might have a new best friend like he's
unbelievable the coolest guy if I wasn't
doing the podcast I don't know if I
would have met him if it just worked out
it worked out that I got to meet this
incredible
person well Rick we covered most of the
most frequently asked questions and
you've been extremely gracious with your
time and thoughtfulness in answering
them and um I don't know what to say
except thank you for taking the time to
do yet another podcast to answer the
audience's questions they were here in
this podcast in the form of this very
large stack of of questions
and of course your book includes a lot
of information that encapsulates this
but I think this really fleshes out some
of the the details of like how you go
about things how certain things can't be
the same for everybody and um I think in
answering these questions you provided a
great service to people who are perhaps
still struggling with getting the
creative process going or flowing um I'm
certain that it's going to change the
way that I focus and lean into my day
I've got a number of different notes
here and maybe I'll be willing to share
them with people but then that would go
against the principle of this is for me
and everyone's going to work it out
their own way so we'll provide links to
everything that was mentioned where
there's a link that's relevant and yeah
man I want just want to say thank you so
much for being such an incredible
educator and such an incredible friend
as well thank you it's a funny idea of
being an educator I can't imagine that
but I appreciate the uh I appreciate
those words well you are indeed an
educator we're learning so much from you
and and if you just step back for a
second and think about all the creative
works that have stemmed and are going to
stem from the learnings that people have
achieved from hearing your experience in
wisdom it's um incalculable wow I'll
take it thank you sir thank you for
joining me for today's discussion about
protocols for creativity with the one
and only Rick Rubin please also be sure
to check out the links in the show note
captions in particular to Rick's
incredible book all about the creative
process entitled the creative act a way
of being if you're learning from and or
enjoying this podcast please subscribe
to our YouTube channel that's a terrific
zeroc cost way to support us in addition
please subscribe to the podcast on both
Spotify and apple and on both Spotify
and apple you can leave us up to a fstar
review if you have questions for me or
comments about the podcast or guess
you'd like me to consider on the hubman
Lab podcast please put those in the
comment section on YouTube I do read all
the comments please also check out the
sponsors mentioned at the beginning and
throughout today's episode that's the
best way to support this podcast not so
much on today's episode but on many
previous episodes of The huberman Lab
podcast we discuss supplements while
supplements aren't necessary for
everybody many people derive tremendous
benefit from them for things like
improving sleep for hormone support and
for improving Focus to learn more about
the supplements discussed on the
huberman Lab podcast go to live momentus
spelled o so Liv mous.com
huberman if you're not already following
me on social media I am huberman lab on
Instagram X formerly called Twitter
LinkedIn Facebook and threads and at all
of those places I discuss science and
science related tools some of which
overlaps with the content of the
huberman Lab podcast but much of which
is distinct from the content covered on
the hubman Lab podcast so again it's
huberman lab on all social media
channels if you haven't already
subscribed to our neural network
newsletter our neur Network newsletter
is a zeroc cost newsletter that comes
out every month it includes podcast
summaries as well as protocols in the
form of short PDFs of maybe just one to
three pages where I list out the
specific protocols for instance for
improving dopamine functioning or for
improving your sleep or for deliberate
cold exposure deliberate heat exposure
or Fitness protocols and on and on all
of which are presented in brief fashion
very direct just the protocols listed
out again completely zero cost to sign
up you simply go to huberman lab.com go
to the menu function scroll down to
newsletter and enter your email and I
should point out that we do not share
your email with anybody thank you once
again for joining me for today's
discussion with Rick Rubin and last but
certainly not least thank you for your
interest in
[Music]
science